it's a crime that is notoriously
difficult to prosecute last year just
1.7 percent of reported rapes led to a
criminal charge the lowest number in a
decade rape is an underreported crime is
estimated that only about 15% of people
who experience sexual violence actually
end up going to the police so we wanted
to investigate how the system is
treating people who do decide to report
and whether they get in the support that
they need so at the end of last year I
was raped in my bedroom by somebody that
I knew that I had previously met before
somebody that I trusted and then you
made the decision to go to the police
yes I reported it basically hours after
it happened and since reporting it I've
just felt a massive lack of support that
day was like the hardest day because I
spent ten hours in a room with male
police officers couldn't see my family
couldn't see any friends no one was
allowed to even know where I was and
since then I just don't feel that I've
been given any support or any help it's
just unbelievable really when I mean
even reporting it must be a very
difficult decision to make
yeah I thought I was doing the right
thing and I thought because I had
reported it hours after I thought that
that's putting me in the best position
that's what you're told to report as
soon as possible I'm keen to kind of
talk about a couple of the issues that
you've experienced and first thing you
had to hand your phone over yeah so I
didn't hand it over straight away
because they took the perpetrators phone
and I assumed that would be enough I
wasn't really sure why they had to take
mine but then a few months later they
did ask for mine and yet they've had it
this entire year to be honest I didn't
mind giving it up because I would do
anything for my case basically it's more
that they've had it for so long and I
should have been given monthly updates
and I wasn't I had to chase the police a
lot to find out what's happening it's
more that they haven't dealt with it
like they've now decided not to even use
it so I'm confused why they even took it
in the first place another actually
experiences around counseling and just
explained cos I think my viewers to be
quite alarmed I guess to know what the
situation is with accessing counseling
before trial yeah so you can have
pretrial therapy is what it's called and
is literally described as a limited
counseling
in the definition of it you can't talk
about the one reason that you need the
counseling so you're not allowed to talk
about anything that is in your police
notes which is obviously what happened
to you
and that's because it can all be used as
evidence the defense can request your
notes then some parts of what you said
can be used against you or the therapist
can be seen to be guiding you over what
happened or what to say if it does go to
court how important do you think
counseling is how much would it benefit
you to be able to just talk freely I
think it massively would have helped me
I think so many people credit counseling
and therapy as being life-changing as it
being this amazing thing where it can
really really help you and really be
beneficial to you and it's really
frustrating for me that I felt like I
desperately needed it and I haven't been
able to have that and then the third
issue that has been a really big issue
for you it's been housing hasn't it so
because it happened in my bedroom again
this is because I reported it you'll
then not allow back there because it
becomes a crime scene so until the
police go to your room or your flat or
wherever it happened and take everything
they need you are not allowed back there
and then obviously when you are allowed
back there it then becomes a very
difficult place to be and to live so I
went to the council for help and I was
told that if you're fleeing sexual
violence or domestic abuse they do not
have to help you so I was told that from
their point of view they could argue you
have intentionally made yourself
homeless it was so upsetting because I
think a lot of the time we think that
survivors aren't believed and I don't
think that that's the issue
the issue isn't that you're not believed
is that you're not heard is that you're
reaching out for help and it's the same
with mental health as well people reach
out for help and they're trying to get
help and the fact is the help isn't
there and it's not being given so where
have you been living so I was put in a
hostel after a while of waiting I was
put in a hostel and it was a hostel with
ninety percent men did you feel safe no
I didn't the floor on the hostel that
was women only constantly have male
residents on and I constantly had to
write written complaints to get myself
out of there and to get myself moved
somewhere appropriate I had to fight to
be taken seriously that that place
wasn't suitable for me what's your
message to
any politician who might be listening to
this interview know what needs to happen
I think that we need to actually listen
to what survivors are saying that they
want and that they shouldn't be deciding
what's best for us open up the
conversation if we're saying that we
want counseling then I feel we should be
able to have that and that there
shouldn't be an argument against that
especially from you know people who
haven't been through it and haven't
experienced it
Sarah Greene the co-director at the end
violence against women coalition says
that this is not an isolated case
so women's organizations around the
country are seeing increasingly worrying
justice outcomes so we're seeing a big
fall in the numbers of cases that
actually get charged there might be a
bit of an investigation and then no
charge we are sure that the bar has been
raised on charging cases so a huge surge
like an almost tripling in the numbers
of people reporting rate to the police
and that is recent rapes as well as
rapes that may have happened a long time
ago and then at the same time we've got
this fall-off in the numbers of cases
that actually get charged there's a very
low chance now frankly that if you
report a rape you make the initial
police call or visit you will ever end
up in court it's something like one in
25 of those reports are ending up in
court only a few years ago that was one
in five and you know we need to be
looking at this this is urgent the
government is holding a review into how
raping serious sexual offences are
handled by the justice system and
pressure is mounting from politicians
such as Labor's Shami Chakrabarti for
them to act rape cases are particularly
difficult and therefore particularly
sensitive to a lack of resources and
indeed to demoralize professionals I
have no doubt I have no doubt that
people are being put off coming forward
this is just a national embarrassment it
seems that there is some guidance that
is still in place but dating back to the
early 2000s that is discouraging people
from getting therapy pretrial on the
spurious basis that somehow this will
compromise their credibility as we
is that it will be fair game to argue as
it they're not telling the truth they've
somehow been coached or given a false
memory by a therapist and this is their
by discouraging people from getting a
vital therapy that they need and at a
time when the country is getting to
grips just a little more with mental
health problems after a series of rape
trials collapsed last year it's perhaps
understandable that there's been a
renewed focus or making sure that cases
have a realistic chance of prosecution
but speaking to survivors it's hard not
to conclude that victims are being
failed by the system and the support
that they need just isn't there in a
parliament consumed by brexit and the
theatres of a leadership contest there
is a risk that other issues are being
put on ice now in response to our report
the Crown Prosecution Service sent us a
statement there has been no change of
policy in how the CPS makes charging
decisions in rape cases these offences
can have a devastating impact will
always seek to prosecute where there is
sufficient evidence to do so there are
strict rules which mean that digital
data should only be accessed when it
forms a reasonable line of inquiry and
private information not connected to the
case must not be shared with the defense
all showing courts furthermore witnesses
and complainants should not be
discouraged or prevented from seeking
therapy and counseling before or during
the trial process